[Music]
that's all we doing today
me and news.com slash energy lien guys
check it out get 15% off your first pair
of free shipping internships in
satisfaction guaranteed best underwear
in the world I guarantee it
also guys Squarespace build your website
the Squarespace you know what Kiana uses
Squarespace be like II honor that's
enough reason for anyone the sales
person you're breathtaking go to
Squarespace com
/ Jen and Jillian save 10% off your
first purchase you're all breathtaking
and just be like Keanu for his cool
motorcycle brand he uses Squarespace
that's the sales pitch be like he open
be careful I'm still traumatized from
the other day I was drinking a madrenas
and was open like that sitting on the
table you know because I was just I was
writing my radio show and I just had it
open on the table I'm typing on my
laptop and in the summertime we get a
lot of flies comes loose leave the doors
open and for the dogs
and they drive jillion nuts but I was
finishing like the bottom of my madrenas
and a fly had flown into it and it went
into my mouth it was completely dead it
felt almost like coffee grounds or
something like in my mouth so I spin it
out and it was just the dead fly and I
was so upset you were like actually
traumatize I was so upset you were on
the border you were on the verge of
tears you're almost crying you were
after like 20 minutes after it had
happened you were still affected by it I
screamed I had thought you hurt yourself
I ran from the other room I was like
what happened I was traumatized I was
drinking my delicious coffee and this
fly was like YUM I want some Oh oops
I'm dead in it he was marinated mmm a
copy marinated fly I don't know but that
happens all the time and like you said
happened to you before and like they
just come in and like get on your
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm like
sometimes I'll do like dinner prep so I
can cut chop stuff and measure stuff and
then later on when I'm cooking dinner
it's just like much easier and when I do
that I almost always have to like seal
oh yeah I was [ __ ] but it's really
only in the summer and it's technically
something right we just had this day
this also stole it
which was a very very foggy cold day but
yeah they like everyone's like why do
you leave your doors open if it's if
there's lice
we have dogs and it won't be outside
beautiful out yeah it was so nice having
the door open but yeah I mean we could
find a better solution other than
zapping them once they come in or just
drinking them out of our coffee oh we
shouldn't put like a screen door or like
a screen like a hanging thing yeah I
mean that still prevents the dogs from
walking in and out
oh wait keep the doors open though yeah
but do remember in the old place when
you had the brilliant idea to just hang
fly tape in front of the door and it was
so sticky and so messy and it got all
over the door that might have been the
grossest thing I've ever done yeah yeah
if I just like hang him at the door like
hanging into the door well I would hang
I hang him hung on outside mm-hmm and so
when the wind blew like blew the fly
tape into the grass door and then unless
this really nasty residue that literally
would never come it was so bad it was a
good truck pretty sure that residue
still there at the hottest it has to be
[ __ ] that place what that place is right
anyway enough about fly tape residue
today we're gonna do some laughs
guessing I compiled a handful of
different laughs well because it was
something that I was gonna do for you I
was like we should play a game called
both laugh is that Oh
but usually I'm the one compiling all
the clips for you to guess but you went
and did it for me so I can guess that's
really fun I like guessing - this was a
surprisingly like bizarre one to
research and get clips for because
there's a well when you type in /
name laughing right you either get laugh
compilations of them like so-and-so
laughing for two minutes straight or you
get try not to laugh someone's hos name
so it's like moments of their work and
it's like funny moments no wandering
you're not a free boy you're in here
stay stay in here but Master has
presented dopey with the sock Dobby is a
free of yes he's gone okay they're up to
no good peachy come they're up - no oh
no no no what is there any food out no I
don't think so but I was sitting in the
living room earlier and I kept hearing
what I thought was peach crying cuz I
thought she was in the office with you
like in the game room and I keep hearing
her crying and I'm like I'm like it
sounds like it's coming from behind me
so I turn around and she's sitting at
the kitchen island at the one of those
tall barstools staring at some treats
that were on the island that were too
far for her tickets she was just sitting
there reminding me that she was sitting
in waiting for me to feed them to her so
that she wouldn't steal them can they
get the BART cuffs off of the fridge
downstairs I don't think so
are you sure we probably could well
peaches downstairs I know she jumped
onto the beanbag chair onto the desk and
on top of him madrenas fridge she should
I'm gonna go get honestly I'm gonna go
check yourself we had a little bark
puffs that I brought into the game room
because for those of you that oh my god
keep that boy walks so loud for those of
you that watch our twitch stream usually
around 10:30 or 11:00 p.m. we have what
I like to call yeah yeah time where
bunny decides that you know we try and
take her outside when she gets like
rowdy but she won't do zoomies really
she won't like go and play she wants to
like get your attention and like play
with her toy but we still have some
resource guarding issues so if you go
and grab her toy sometimes she might
growl at you or you pet her when she's
with her toy she might growl at you but
so I was bringing the bark puffs into
that room because we've been working on
this hand signal with quiet so as soon
as she stops barking I reward her and
say quiet you know so she's learning
she's doing really well but that bag of
bark puffs
still in that room unattended right now
on top of the refrigerator okay
what tell me what was she doing
take a guess where you think she was in
the pantry no on the island on the
island what beach she was standing on
the island looking at me like what
that's where she was earlier today she
figured out that she's in Ireland
I know because if we leave the barstools
even out a little bit she can jump on
them and then jump onto the island what
are you doing what are you doing unreal
we bring her up here to podcasts we
leave the door open because buddy did
not come with us so we wanted to just in
case bunny decided she wanted to come up
we left the door open but peach use that
as an opportunity to go out the door go
downstairs so no one's paying attention
and get on the island and she is a ninja
she leaves a room and you do not know
like you don't like all the sudden she's
just not here you don't even notice her
leaving ever you just cut her nails - so
there's no sound she's got little cat
feet right now and now this one's crying
at me on the floor I'm sorry - help me
please please help me she's a good girl
anyways anyway so I went and clipped
like 21 or 22 I can't remember how many
I'm excited I never get to guess clips
of laughter so me without further ado
let's just get let's just jump right
into it
hopefully it's fun to play along - yeah
so you guys will be able to play along
we'll give you a second obviously
Jenna's gonna guess I know the answers a
few of them are just the most potato
quality you've ever imagined okay
someone recording their friend recording
their other friend recording off of
their phone like that kind of and then I
left a few a little longer of the ones I
enjoyed okay so the good laughs are
longer is there any are they like
celebrities using okay alright ready I'm
ready boy more Easter
is I know that is I'm gonna give the
audience's okay here no you can say they
can part they can pause and
1,000,000% Seth Rogen except there he
has a very distinct laugh he was like
the first person I thought of
it's one for one really good ten out of
ten laugh some of them are also really
hurt
okay I know exactly who that is that one
was not hard that is Shane Dawson you
guys Dawson it probably wasn't too hard
to find a Shane Dawson laughing
compilation nope a lot of nope a lot of
them are they really there was a few of
these that I like had a lot of material
to use I kind of like watching people
laugh yeah it's a little fun I made a
compilation of you laughing from one
night you did when we were watching
commercial cuts that was a fun night
I had crazy hair I actually never mind
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you kind of stumped no I'm not kind
of stumped it just sounds like first of
all very familiar okay
second of all it sounds I realized
listening to that that I feel like I
know multiple people that laughs like
that hmm interesting I think you're
right
it's on like the tip of my brain who
that is Kermit oh my god
but I you know who else that sounds like
gabs that does yeah it's not her will
you play it again
yeah is that Trisha Paytas yes oh hell
yeah nice sounds good it's like that was
so weird
I feel like it sounds like someone I
know but also another person that I know
but I you you probably wouldn't pick
gabs no that was Trisha
gabs is our friend she's married to
Jason
Sully who we play games with a lot he's
our friend but it would be really
obscure that's actually the more thing
about it does sound like her laughs and
it's just really hard it shows is more
like pronounced and a little mousey er
yes yeah but you got it first guests
thank you I'm moving on that's you what
has me
you think this is me you're welcome for
that one and just had to put that in
there well that that last portion of
that little laugh compilation you played
I edited I know and if you didn't get
that there's something really wrong like
really wrong my life has changed a
little bit over the years
yeah but it's remained the same style of
laughs mm-hmm
so that was it's also getting wheezy er
bye
today you know that like long wheeze
that you do is like is very dad it
matters or mustache you have going on
right now what do you think of this - I
love your stache
you're under arrest oh who you arresting
him for what that guy over there he
stole are you a cop or is this a
citizen's arrest
it's just my finger come over here we're
all very intimidated officer I'm
actually gonna attempt my first cosplay
oh why don't you say Oh God why can't I
talk about my cosplay it's my new hobby
I'm a cosplayer okay you you kids almost
Hoss players can't say it's your new
hobby if you've never done I'm gonna do
it and I will it will be my new hobby
but it already is cuz I'm excited about
it
I already bought the first piece do you
want to know the first piece that I
bought
yeah but right here okay you can't buy
your mustache you guys that's what they
tell you but you can but I agree this
I'm gonna be cosplaying as a siege
operator
his name's warden and he is a Secret
Service agent with a great mustache and
nothing to lose
and a tiny gun and he runs like this he
runs our creepy I'm actually into it I
know I know that well I'm sure someone
else will do it better probably 10 other
people will do it better probably a
thousand honestly but I want to try it
because I've never felt so like I've
never seen a video game character I've
been like just so spiritually connected
you know so I just feel like that is
that is who I want to become that is the
final form that I want to achieve you
understand the people that don't know
who you're talking about
are taking you seriously right now but
you're spiritually buzzing with the
video kinda take me seriously when I
talk that's the goal this is one giant
meme he looks like me a literal
manifestation of Ned Flanders holding a
gun yeah he does but that's like that's
me I could be that I just need a couple
pieces of equipment and then could photo
shoot that I'll be good to go I can't
stand you moving on who's that am I
supposed to not get that next one this
is bad quality on this one that's good
is he like there's a few of them that I
just know that you'll get because we've
watched so many times but that was
pretty good cuz the quality was also
know that I don't know I love Conan
who's that ariana grande thank you
okay this next one is dedicated to you
specifically oh I like that I have no
idea that sounds like my cousin yeah it
is no oh are stumped yeah let's play it
again so like the second bout of his
laughter it's more in tune with his
actual laughter he this is him like
laughing for like a scene it's not him
like breaking character and really
laughing it's like his fake laughing
it's like you know it's traumatized so
you're trolling me I'm not honest
I have no idea that is your trolling I'm
not trolling you I think you can get
this is it Greg Kinnear from stuck on
you from the actual movie stuck on you
no come on I wouldn't lower that
cinematic masterpiece to a silly little
game like this sounds like I don't know
jack black but it's not no it's not
I mean honestly out of context is a
really [ __ ] hard one I don't know
that it was like I had to struggle to
find some I was struggling to find some
clips of this guy laughing and this is
kind of what I got but like I said it's
not his actual laugh it's him laughing
in character yeah how am I supposed to
get time I don't know think about it
this way mmm you want a hint how about I
give you a hint okay
okay so he's I'll just I'll explain
what's happening in the scene
he's a cigar in his mouth his feet are
up on the chair
and he's smiling while he smugly laughs
at a person I was frantically counting
money don't think that helps me okay
they're in New York mm they're in an
apartment building his name rhymes with
Mary spine Feld Jerry yeah that's not
what his laugh sounds like that is a
trick laughs it's it's a hard one I told
you I got this you tricked me okay if
I'm gonna make him all easy what's the
fun here I had to give you a little
curve ball and that was a curveball that
was him being dramatic laughing in
character fair enough
you just you're troll for that I'm not
it's a funny scene it's this thing right
here where he has the cigar in his mouth
there's like a million outtakes of it
cuz she kept laughing and he did it it's
actually really funny to know have you
ever watched that show
[Laughter]
Wow gee who's our no idea it's my own
mother it's you love me the Debbie
mission Debbie machine she is such a
cute laughs honestly one of my favorite
laughs next to yours she's got a really
good laugh yeah my sushis shirt on it's
a great shirt keep up the great work
Debbie okay the next one ready mm-hmm
[Laughter]
that was bleeding into say who's that
first one that's Felix that's PewDiePie
PewDiePie easy yeah these are easy all
right so who was that first one that was
Tana mojo how did you know that cuz she
laughs very like she has a very
distinctive yeah
she was a distinct voice and a distinct
laugh yeah good you're blazing through
these thank you okay sorry the first one
don't pay attention the last thing that
with me just don't pay attention lasting
you okay I'm not sure you don't think
you know that one you play it again I
[Laughter]
feel like a lot of you guys watching and
listening or you've already got it
easily this was an easy clap you have to
play it again there's a david dobrik
damn yes thank you
that I don't know I just thought about
it sounds good thank you
okay the next one good guess their next
one's good okay I know who that is and I
know what they're laughing at oh I was
gonna ask you that what are they
laughing at that's me mm-hmm and that's
me laughing at the first time I ever saw
hub G oh you're good at this game yeah
that was a funny night
because I was dying it was it was back
when there was only third person in pop
G so you see your own character and I
was also back when it was early access
so the game was not pretty it was like
derpy there's the zone very robotic and
weird it was so deep and we were just in
a house like crouching and standing up
and going prone and crouching and that
we thought it was so funny tipped me
fully over the entity over the [ __ ]
edge - it could not did you look at my
phone no you could not what handle it
okay I left us I left this one a little
longer because it's a enjoyable
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that is my educated guess is the skinny
legend herself Mariah Carey yes I adore
her that was the fun one her laugh
compilation is mostly just for going
[Laughter]
[Music]
laughing being done with it
I loved her when I was growing up she
was that [ __ ] did you have a poster on
your wall no but I bought like all of
her albums every single one I loved them
I would play them on my boombox in the
shower that's a safety hazard actually
what no it's not putting a boombox
inside of a shower if it's a visit
actually in the bathroom Julie in the
shower okay
that's her what the hell it was that
that was like seven different people oh
it's not that was all one person
how can I have any laughs come on one
person I don't know the answer to that
question I'm just here to I'm the
messenger okay it was like an audience
laughing I told you it's hard I know I
know but that could be a clue okay play
it again
[Laughter]
it sounds like a female okay do I'm
gonna tell you yes or no or sure yes
okay it's a female I'm sorry just
watching that video I'm not sure hmm
okay I'm trying to think of someone
whose voice sounds like that it's hard
to like describe this person in the form
of like hints and clues mm-hmm but the
audience is it is a little indicator
that there's a live audience wherever
she's laughing yeah and she has a lot of
different [ __ ] laughs I mean oh this
is really hard when I almost I can give
you more clues if you want we play it
again yeah
[Laughter]
I don't know what you're watching but I
want to know I don't know man I don't
know Rachael Ray no but close really
well in a sense that they're both on TV
Oh tight she has her own show and the
show's name is her name ah mmm time she
passed out on stage Oh Wendy will ya oh
damn that was Wendy Williams Wow
what were you watching over and over
again the videos of her laughing okay
it was just like hilarious looking
moments unintentionally hilarious yeah
damn I don't watch a lot of Wendy
Williams but that's a good one that's a
good laugh that's a good 10 or so laughs
yeah it was like doesn't sound like the
same person you know was also hilarious
what that some people think me and these
are not the softest underwear you can
get when in reality me and ease is three
times softer than cotton made of micro
modal fabric and it is the most
comfortable underwear you can get also
with really cool new styles and couples
pairs hilarious right this episode is
brought to you by me undies guys you
should buy me and he's for your bum they
have amazing underwears and socks and
bra let's and onesies that I actually
wore last night while I was streaming
the pineapple one the pineapple onesie I
honestly love onesies for like gaming I
think it's like the perfect outfit for
when you're playing video games or
watching TV or watching a movie or
reading a book or eating a meal or doing
the opposite of eating a meal or running
around the backyard or rolling around in
your house or sleeping or waking up
showering your house yeah whatever you
do me and ease should be on your bum
literally three times softer than cotton
it's an incredible incredible texture
that you just have to feel
believe is so soft so comfortable and
they last really long my whole entire
closets for me in these and right now
you can get me on this for 15% off and
free shipping also guys you should know
that me and E's are sustaining
sustainably manufactured from a carbon
neutral process while simultaneously
capturing excess chemicals so they know
what they're doing they're not hurting
the environment okay they're just making
a great product that you can now buy so
click the link below go to me and he's
calm slash annejulien for 15% off and
100% of satisfaction guarantee you will
love them that's it
also guys Squarespace you should use
square space because Keanu uses square
space you're breathtaking thank you
for real over 200,000 companies use
Squarespace and in addition to Keano
idris elba who I also adore and love use
a Squarespace for their own personal
projects that they do Keanu being his
really cool motorcycle brand and what's
great about Squarespace is it's a very
user friendly experience they make it
accessible to people who may not know
anything about a website they have 24/7
customer support they have live webinars
and then just the interface and the
templates that they give you are very
easy to understand and fun to build a
website with to personalize it however
you want it to be personalized so you
can get a free trial go to
squarespace.com / - no Julian or use
that link to get 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain and
again Keanu does it so you should too
that's it ready to move on I got a few
more Randy I got one the font size 2 3 4
5 6 I think I have 6 more okay I'm ready
okay you blew through these so thank
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is that my initial guess is that it's a
nerd ruse wiki from Shane Dawson's
channel , oh that's it that's the only
guess I thought you're gonna say that
was my initial guess but then there was
another one no I think that's my guess
correct it's as you said yeah yeah
pretty distinctive laughs yeah and you
hear it a lot in his videos it's a fun
way it's a very fun laughs yeah
it is super infectious yeah like he
could start laughing at something that's
not funny at all and I would start
laughing because he's laughing can we be
all laughing then and Garrett too has
the same type of laugh and Shane the
older parents laugh oh yes you have
y'all just they have that laugh this one
is non-infectious this is a very weird
laugh okay here we go
I know okay I the only reason I know who
that is is because there's Mission
Impossible playing in the background
it's Tom Cruise that is the scariest
last manner it's like not coming from a
place of laughter at all no that's like
sneering laugh is that from that
interview where he's talking about it
that famous oh my god play it again that
is terrifying you can like you can sense
that it's not a real laugh
oh my god like really scary wait
listening to the laughter without the
odd like the visual of it is oh I don't
even think about that because I've been
watching it I mean no no I'm picturing
is the interview because I've seen it so
many times it's so pretty it's pretty
creepy
it's like devoid of happiness it's a
laughter devoid of happiness that's what
that is
it's weird should I start laughing like
that no am I am I know how am i know
next one you ready to move on from Tom
Cruise or you want to TQ talking about
Tom Cruise he I don't think that's
really hard
oh [ __ ] I thought you're gonna get that
one okay the first part sounds like it's
on a podcast okay are you playing it
again
yep damn is this own I'm supposed to
know I think you I think you've seen
this person laugh I think like you've
probably watched one of these clips
before probably not like the last part
of it specifically but the clip entirely
like you know this person you know who
they are
you've heard them laugh you like it's
like in the front of my brain and I
can't pull it out I can do it one more
time it it is in the front of your brain
I can tell by your reaction and I know
that you know it so let's try over to
[Laughter]
see that sounds like The Breakfast Club
okay use that you use that but it's not
Charlemagne no it's not sure so it had
to have been a guest on The Breakfast
Club use that as well you're getting
much warmer
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a funny laugh so they're there they
might be a musician or a comedian or I
mean think about the guests on the
breakfast but the primary people though
they have musicians yeah so let's think
about that it was like gucci mane no
it's not Soulja Boy it's not Drake Drake
it's not from that interview I know you
wouldn't put Takashi 6:9 I didn't know
um oh my god think about here I'll give
you a hint there was a lot of clips of
this person
laughing they laugh a lot which should
give clues to like what type of person
they are suppose alone yes you did it
it's possible yeah that's once I had
like Breakfast Club and who would be
laughing a lot on The Breakfast Club
it's possible yeah look at you detective
okay okay he has a good luck yeah he
does he has a good laugh I'm like this
next person here we go Julianne you can
use the incessant clapping as a clue as
well it's Jimmy Fallon I mean the club
quality of that it's terrible
oh my god you can tell them you can tell
but that that is a testament to how
distinct distinctive that sound is it's
also devoid of happiness devoid of
happiness it's fake and there's just
non-stop clapping like you know
he toy it's that's what that is yeah
that was Jimmy Fallon there's a lot of
last confirmations of him and not from
like people who are fans it's like
there's like titles like Jimmy Fallon
fake laughing ignoring what his guest is
saying while laughing for yeah I mean
the more I don't watch him but the more
I was watching those clips I was
actually kind of like oh my god he's
like you can see him preparing the
laughs and then firing away on it like
on a certain moment in his brain without
listening to anything why like what's
wrong with the show that's just like a
realistic approach to having a little
sit-down with someone nothing they pick
the stories beforehand they already know
what they're all gonna say you know what
I mean they know the games that they're
gonna play they know all that stuff
before him and the Jimmy Fallon most
often knows the story as well because
he's the one asking the questions about
the specific story yeah so why fake it
well I think it I think maybe some
people who are in positions like that
where they're hosting a show of the live
audience feel like if I'm laughing the
audience is gonna laugh and then why
we're at this way where does that
pressure come from like where's what's
the problem with just having a normal
show I don't think there is one I just
think that like he's gotten so used to
that being that works quote-unquote
right like if he laughs really loud and
a lot no one can like look at the
interview and be like that was awkward
or that was bad or this was a bad
interview it's like they're laughing so
it must be good you don't I mean yeah
but I think your point is completely
valid it's like what the [ __ ] wrong
with just sitting down and like telling
a story or asking questions they're
talking and laughing when it comes
naturally nothing isn't it to just have
a guest that's talking about something
without the pressure of it being
unbelievably nice laughingly hysterical
that's it's literally a meme at this
point so he either just doesn't care
he's like doesn't know how to do it any
other way I don't know anyway on to a
better one
cool much better one
oh my goodness oh is Bazaar my dude
do you've any idea again if I had to
guess like somebody that I'm not super
familiar with it's like mama June or
somebody like laughs it sounds like a
southern lady laughs okay I don't know
where she's from
I don't think of her as a southern lady
damn you got the lady part right I
[ __ ] up
she's been a part of some very very
famous movies they'd be like Kathy Bates
no good guys though I don't I have no
idea genuinely I have no idea she was in
one of my favorite movies of all time
oh no is it cher yes sure it's cher
that's cher laughing that's [ __ ] Cher
yeah are you kidding me no it's weird
isn't it yeah I don't believe that I was
sure look she's laughed like that
multiple times
oh my god its share laughing its share
laughing is she laughing she's a good
laugh it is a good laugh I mean it makes
sense looking at it coming out of her
mouth it makes sense but to just hear
that yeah does not so it doesn't I'm
thinking about that yeah you have to be
watching it I think oh my god okay this
next was probably the hardest one or you
might get it really easily but I think
it's hard I'm just because I couldn't
find like an extended long good laugh I
had to find two little clips of like a
quiet version of the laughs and then the
louder version but this is not long so
if you don't I can give you hints ready
actually that's not even fair that's all
I have
yeah I can't that's not even fair I
can't even gather I'm realizing now that
it's not anything that was is that
Ronnie from the Jersey I couldn't find
the good cousin doing the route laugh oh
yeah it's really loud alright ready two
more who's that
I have no idea one of them sounds like a
talk show but I have no idea okay all
right well play it again
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's like a very like kid sounding
laughs one of them
I heard almost like a no like a British
accent or an Australian no no I think
they might be British and or Australian
Joe I think it they're a woman they are
women so maybe Emilia Clarke Nicole
Kidman doesn't sound like either of them
though mm-hmm that like what is that one
it's bizarre like I'm not gonna lie like
wait wouldn't she just laughed and said
okay like that clip
it's a weird laugh it's like a very
light timid sounding laugh and then the
other one there's like something amazing
happen but the general theme of this
person's laugh is like childish like
sounding very innocent sounding but like
also like a timid laugh like very quiet
almost yeah that doesn't help me cuz I
can hear that you know I just don't know
who it is
[Laughter]
she's blonde she's a pop star a timid
blonde pop star timid laughing blonde
pop star well she she's blonde when she
has hair see ya
one time she didn't have her Katy Perry
cuz she shaved it all off Britney Spears
yes that was Bruce Lee oh yeah here look
what was that
no no it's kind of weird there's like
sodium that was hard yeah I could under
I could pick out Britney Spears laughs
but I just didn't and I couldn't yeah I
mean I probably could have got more
clips but like it always I don't know
see I remember her laughing very like
hehehe it was always like hehe yeah I
know you're Mia like mm Brittany laugh
is like ha ha hee hee this is the first
couple ones were like some old
interviews when she's like ok ok super
vote you used to laugh like like [ __ ]
full-out hee ha ha no a little kid no
okay but I wasn't really tuned in as
much as me no ok last one here we go
ahead ready after ready for this is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's scary
yes sorry Garrett got you that's Garrett
as Garrett I told you taught you it's
such a good laugh
I had to finish on my favorite one I
lied I said I never heard him laugh but
I got you
misdirection it's fun watching people
laugh right except for Tom Cruise
that's scary do it again how do you not
laugh when that person's laughing it's
impossible for me unless you're someone
that's like super annoyed by other
people laughing then maybe yeah but no
to me it's like if I hear that it makes
me laugh yeah every time well I hope I
did okay I think you did that was fun if
you did pretty well
there was a couple that stumped you that
I wasn't expecting to stump you like the
Britney and the cher I thought you would
get but then again it makes sense that
you didn't now that I'm kind of thing
they were very hard
who did you nail right away that was
impressive though I was impressed that
you problem solved to post Malone that
was a good one mm-hmm you got Ari on it
right away yeah most of them most of
them were pretty easy for you I'm
curious how you guys did did you did
anyone get a hundred percent no one okay
some homework Hart Jerry Seinfeld
laughing in character is hard I could
honestly I wanted to give you a Seinfeld
one and I didn't want it to be easy
because what's a fun layup it's boring
who's laugh is that oh no it's it's
across the screen crying screaming right
that was really fun though
yeah I would be interested to see how
you do though uh well with that same
difficulty level I would probably
struggle very heavily I'd be bad yeah I
was like I don't know it's kind of hard
to also choose people to like who do I
pick for this yeah I was like trying to
find a good mix of people if he gets a
throw Ronnie Barkan we would have had to
end it right away
this is
he isn't even wearing doubt well anyway
I hope you guys enjoyed listening to
Jenna guess laughter with fun bow fufu
just barked she literally has a timer
it's like towards the end of the podcast
so she knows oh she's not barking right
now she just barked one time well we got
to go down to our Bork toddler but thank
you guys for listening and hanging out
with us for another week of the Jenna
Jillian podcast yeah and we'll be back
next week for some more high-flying
action but we'll be doing the laughing
next was really fun yeah you guys have a
good week we'll see ya bye
[Music]